everyone loses their mind once a year
when it's pumpkin season literally big
go crazy laughs mmm much doesn't know
it's delicious kind of graham crackery
look a crouton delicious crouton super
dry well yeah it's meant it's meant to
be like dipped in the liquid I would dip
this in a Starbucks pumpkin spice latte
we got to get it on this is there that
yeah we got it
BRB becoming a farmer what's delicious
it looks weird a lot of sugar how come
pumpkin automatically implies like 10
times yeah I don't think it's supposed
to because pumpkins don't have sugar
they like squashes right squash the
sugar out of pumpkins I hate this word
but I'm gonna use it it is kind of moist
on the inside I'm now wondering what
pumpkin tastes like I'm not really sure
what I can do why no it's like marmalade
applesauce baby food oh my god it does
miss like applesauce Oh I'm not mad at
this actually I am I don't know do I
like this I think you may like it who is
the first person who tried to eat a
pumpkin
this is just too cute from the get-go
I'm telling you that it's adorable
thank you oh I like this I love it
it sounds like no I thought I was like
mmm and I'm like okay the pumpkin tastes
pumpkin 'i'm the tardis chart this is
how and it's small
Wow America good job today pumpkin beer
I think is something I can give you a
head let's just made my day I get a
little spice at the end
Ralph's Costco banana beef oh yeah that
was delicious I would drink that bottle
oh I think where we are with pumpkins
it's fine just let's just keep pumpkins
at a distance and pumpkins could just
realize it like who they are natural and
alone is enough we see a revolution it's
a lot of hype and it's just not that big
of a deal because you know what's around
the corner Christmas I think pumpkins
more state of mind
yeah I never happened to fire one
something